ก็
จะแสกสวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียม
สวัสดีค่ะครูเลี้ยงม.มทำอะไรอยู่คะสวัสดี
ค่ะพี่เอ๋แค่บันทึก
บันทึกใช่ไหมคะกดแล้ว
โอเคกดวันที่กำลังอ่าน
อ่านการ์ด
ก๊าซก๊าซและกัดปีใหม่เหรอคะให้ค่ะการ
เปลี่ยนว่าสวัสดีปีใหม่ขอ
เป็นรูปอะไรอ่ะมี
รูปถ้วยเบญจรงค์
ถ้วยแล้วก็มีสีเบญจรงค์ benben จะแปลว่า 5
โรงแปลว่าสีแปลว่าถ้วยห้าสีละห้าๆ
เบญจรงค์เบญจรงค์นะคะแล้วก็ปีข้างล่างมี
พวงมาลัยดคะใช่ค่ะมีพวงมาลัยพวงมาลัยนะคะ
สวยจังเลยเดี๋ยวให้บุหรี่เอ่อคุณเรียมยัง
ยังมีการ์ดปีใหม่หรอคะครูเอ๋น่ะตอนนี้
เป็นการ์ดอ่ะออนไลน์อ๋อ
นี่ 5 ตอนนี้ก็ยังมีการ์ดปีใหม่ใส่ใส่ซอง
ใส่ซองสีขาวนะคะๆ 243
นี้ครูเรียมกำลังส่งการ์ดให้เพื่อนหรือ
เพื่อนสงกรานต์ให้ครูเรียมค่ะอันนี้คือ
เพื่อน
ส่งการ์ดมาเพื่อนส่งมาให้ครูเรียมครู
เรียมก็เลยอ่าใช่ค่ะเพราะว่า
การ์ดปีใหม่
ต้องมาเดือนมกราคมค่ะ
เดือนมกราคมแต่ตอนนี้เดือนกุมภาพันธ์นี้
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ค่ะพี่โอ๊ยโอ๊ยเดี๋ยวเรา
ยังไม่ได้เขียนวันที่ 10 มั้ยใช่ค่ะวัน
นี้วันที่เท่าไหร่แล้วคะวันนี้นะคะอ่ะวัน
นี้เดี๋ยวกู f แค่สกี้ก่อนอุ้ยคู๋ลืมลบ
วันนี้อาหาร
วันนี้วัน
วันวันเสาร์เนาะ
ใช่ค่ะวันนี้วันเสาร์
วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่นะคะวันที่
12 ค่ะวันที่ 12 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ปีพตตปีพตต
2015 ร้อย 65
2565 ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2000  22 ค่ะ
2022 มีการค้าอ่าตอนนี้นะคะตอนนี้เวลา
เวลา
18:00 น
06:44 นาทีนะคะชนยังไม่ตกนะฝนยังไม่ตก
เมื่อกี้เราทำคลิปฝนตกแล้วคุยก็ไปแล้วก็
กลับมาเอ้ยกูดินดูอะไรนะคะค่ะเตรียมกำลัง
ดูก๊าซนะคะ
จากที่มัดการ์ดปีใหม่ใช่มีคนอื่นให้
เตรียมมาในเดือนมกราคมในเดือนมกราคมใช่
ค่ะเดือนมกราคมนะคะ
เดือนมกราคมมีคนส่งการ์ดปีใหม่ให้ครู
เรียมมกราคมเป็นปีใหม่วันที่ 1 วันที่ 1
ปีใหม่ผู้เตรียมวันที่ 1 กุมภาพันธ์ก็ปี
เอ้อใช่มั้ย
ใช่เหรอคะใช่ปีใหม่
ปีใหม่ 1 มกราคม
วันที่ 1 กุมภาพันธ์ปีใหม่
วันที่ 1 มกราคมปีใหม่วันที่ 1
กุมภาพันธ์ด้วยบินในปีใหม่จีนหรือ
ปีใหม่จีนคนจีน
เรียกไว้ตรุษจีนนะคะ
เดี๋ยว
วันวันที่ 1 มกราคมเนี่ยปีใหม่ทั้งโลกเลย
ประเทศไทยได้ยินมั้ยได้ยิน
ของ
ประเทศไทยประเทศอาจญี่ปุ่นประเทศอเมริกา
ประเทศเกาหลีประเทศอะยุโรปปัดประเทศวิทยุ
โรบประเทศอังกฤษทวีปยุโรป
ก็ปีใหม่
ทั้งหมดปีใหม่นะแต่ว่าประเทศไทยน่ะมีปี
ใหม่วันที่ 1 มกราคมปีใหม่วันนี้วันที่ 1
กุมภาพันธ์
สีแดงสีแดงปีใหม่คนไทยจีนอ่ะเราเรียกว่า
ตรุษจีน
ที่ใหม่ของคนไทยเชื้อสายจีนค่ะก็แล้วก็มี
อีกนะมีมีมีสงกรานต์
เดือนเดือนเมษายน
นี้เดินเมษายนใช่ไหมคะ 13 นก๊อปปีใหม่
ถ่ายที่ใหม่ไข่ใช่ใช่ 3 เมษายนที่อเมริกา
มีปีใหม่ไหมคะคิดว่าก็มีมีมีคนไทยว่าคน
ไทยเที่ยววัดไงแต่ของอเมริกาไม่มีมีของคน
ไทยคนไทยอยู่อเมริกาโอเคสงกรานต์ปณ
สงกรานต์ปีใหม่ไทยนะคะที่นี้เนี่ย
คูเรียร์เมื่อกี้ครูเห็นครูเรียมมีการ์ด
นะครับนักเรียนเวลาปีใหม่เนี่ยเราก็จะ
ต้องพูดดีๆใช่ครับใครค่ะตอนนี้คนไทยก็ชอบ
Facebook ชอบลายชอบอีเมลชอบอะไรนะวัด App
App  Instagram
ราคาคนไทยก็จะเขียนเนาะเขียนคำพูดดีๆนะทำ
พูดดีๆเมื่อกี้ครูเรียมก็ดูที่การ์ดนะคะ
การ์ดปีใหม่สถานก็เข้าจะครูเห็นเค้าเขียน
สวัสดี
ปีใหม่นั่งอ๋ออันนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
สวัสดีใหม่สวัสดีปีใหม่นะคะ
โคเรียมอะยังคู่เรียมคนกไก่เนาะใช่ค่ะครู
เอ๋น่ะ 50% ไทย 50% จีนอ๋อส่ง
ของคนจีนเราเรียกว่าตรุษจีนนะคะตรุษจีน
คนไทยจีนก็จะกับนิแต่ตัวเองว่าตอนนะคะ
มีคนไทยจัดตรงนี้ก็มีบ้านแล้วค่ะอยู่บ้าน
แล้วก็มีเพื่อนบ้าน
คนไทยจีนน่ะเขาก็จัดมาเจอหน้ากันอ่ะ
เวลาเจอหน้ากันหน้าก็ปีใหม่ใช่ไหมคนไทย
จริงก็จะพูดกันเอ้ยวันนี้ตึกจีนเฮงๆรวยๆ
นะ
เฮงๆรวยๆ
คืออะไรคะเนื้อเพลงแปลว่าโชคดีดีดีๆแข็ง
แรงๆอาหารดีเราก็รวยก็คืออันนี้เป็นเงิน
อะตอนล่าก็ได้ค่ะหรือเปล่า
รวยมึงเยอะๆใช่แล้วถ้าเพลงเฮงแปลว่าดีโชค
ดีอ่ะ
ธุรกิจดีร้านกายแข็งแรงอันนี้เฮงเฮง
รวยรวยๆก็มีเงินนะคะมีเงินคนไทยจีนก็จะ
พูดพูดสั้นๆก็ได้พูดยาวๆก็ได้แต่นี้ครู
เอ๋ชอบพูดโอ้อาจตรุษจีนเฮงๆรวยๆก็จะพูด
ง่ายๆแล้วเทียมก็ต้องพูดกับตัวเอว่าเฮงๆ
รวยๆค่ะนายเฮงเฮงๆรวยๆ
บางคนก็พูดอ่ะมี
มันมีก็คือมีเงินมีบ้านมีข้าวกินหน้ามีรถ
ไม่รถขับมีเสื้อนะมีแหวน
มีเยอะๆ
อยากมีอะไรมีมั้งมีคือมีมากๆนะแล้วก็สี
สุก
สีสุกไม่สุกสีสุกก็คืออ๋อร่างกายแข็งแรง
ใจ
มีความสุขที่นี่มีความสุขแล้วก็ยิ้ม
ยิ้มมากๆอ่ะเราก็บอกว่ามั่งมีศรีสุขคือมี
เงินมีบ้านมีรถน่ะอ้ะทำงานออฟฟิศ
ถ้ามีเงินมามากๆเป็นครูก็มีนักเรียนมามาก
ๆ
แล้วก็รักใจแข็งแรงยิ้มมีความสุขนะมั่งมี
ศรีสุขมีชื่อเสียงด้วยมีคนรู้จักอ่ะมี
ชื่อเสียงคืนนี้คนมองเห็นคนรู้จักครู
เรียม
โคเออ๋อรู้ว่ากูเอกก็มีช่อง YouTube ใช่
ไหมคะได้คู๋มีช่องยูทูปเออ
กูเรียมก็มีช่อง YouTube ใช่ค่ะถ้าครูเอ๋
บอกว่ามีชื่อเสียงก็คือมีคนเข้ามาปลด
Subscribe กูเอ๋เยอะๆใช่ไหมคะตอนนี้มีคน
Subscribe นิดหน่อยนะคะนักเรียน
ช่วย Subscribe ให้ครูเอ๋ด้วยนะคะ
คอมเพรสเซอร์เบิ้ลไทยด้วย Subscribe นี้
นะคะอ่าใคร conversation แถวเป้นะคะ
Subscribe เรียมไทย Subscribe นะคะ
ขอบคุณเรียงอูเอจะได้มั่งมีศรีสุขนะคะ
แล้วก็ก็มีชื่อเสียงใช่ไหมคะยายมีชื่อ
เสียง
ไม่มีคนรู้จักมากๆนะคะ
อันนี้เป็นค่ะอ่าเป็นคำอวยพรแบบแบบไทยจีน
นะคะแบบไทยจีนก็จะอวยพรให้อ่ะมีเงินแข็ง
แรงร่างกายแข็งแรงใจมีความสุขมีความสุขก็
จะยิ้มเนี่ยมีกันนี้มีความสุข
มีความสุขอันนี้
อันนี้มีความทุกข์อันนี้มีความสุขนัก
เรียนเวลาตรุษจีนนะสุดจีนหรือปีใหม่แปล
จีนวันที่ 1 ของจีแหละห้ามพูดทุก
ไม่ได้นะพูดไม่ดีไม่ได้ต้องพูดอุ้ยเฮงๆ
รวยๆมั่งมีศรีสุขจะบอกโอ้ทำไมคู่เตรียม
หน้าตาเหนื่อยแอบไม่ได้เตรียมร้องหน้า
เหมือนร้องไห้แอบไม่ได้ทำไมคุณเรียมหน้า
ตาโอไม่มีความสุขแปด
เหลี่ยมสวยคูเรียร์ modi
ขอบคุณค่ะเยี่ยมดูแข็งแรง
ใช่ค่ะเรียงก็ชอบชอบอวยพรให้คนอื่นว่าขอ
ให้สวยขึ้นสวยขึ้นนี้ซื้อเดี๋ยวกูเอก
Stock ก็กินก่อนนะจะได้เห็นครูเรียมชัดๆ
ให้ค่ะของนอกคนไทยวันที่ 1 มกราคมอวยพร
ว่าดู
สวยขึ้นสวยขึ้น
ฮ่าๆๆไม่ใช่สวยลงนะคะต้องสวยค่ะสวยขึ้น
ค่ะแสดงว่าอันนี้อวยพรผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะอวยพรผู้หญิงพี่เอ๋ก็เป็นผู้หญิงเรียง
ก็พูดว่าให้พี่เอ๋สวยขึ้นสวยขึ้นขอบคุณ
ค่ะค่ะให้น้องแหละนักเรียนสวยขึ้นสวยขึ้น
แต่โชคดีที่เรามีซูมค่ะซูมทำให้เราสวย
ขึ้นใช่
ถ้าค่าเรียมพูดกับพี่อาร์ตี้ล่ะค่ะเฮีย
ที่เป็นผู้ชายถ้ากูได้บอกครูแอนตี้ปีใหม่
ขอให้สวยขึ้นสวยขึ้นควรที่อื่นนะไม่ๆๆผู้
ชาย
หล่อสุดหล่อขึ้น
หล่อขึ้นตัวที่บอกขอบคุณครับ
หล่อขึ้นขอให้ร่างกายแข็งแรงขอราคา
ใช่พรปีใหม่ราคาพี่เอ๋อยากอยากได้คำ
อวยพรแบบไหนคะคำอวยพรหรอ
ใช่ครูเอ๋
เอาจริงๆนะกูเอะอะอะไรก็ได้
อะไรก็ได้แต่เวลามีใครบอกสวยขึ้นนะเอ๋ให้
สวยขึ้นสวยขึ้นคุยกัน
สงสัยต้องไปคลินิก
มีบางคนบอกว่า
อวยพรให้เรียมว่าคิดอะไรก็ขอให้เรียมได้
อ๋อคิดโทรศัพท์ก็จะ
โทรศัพท์
คลิปลำโพงก็จะมี
โอ้โหคิดอะไรก็ได้อันนั้นใช่ไหมคะคิดอะไร
ก็ได้อะนั้นพี่เอกคิดอะไรคะพี่เอ๋นะเวลา
อวยพรให้คนพี่เอ๋ชอบชอบจริงๆคิดอยากจะบอก
ว่าขอให้ใจมีความสุข
[เพลง]
ใจมีความสุขขอให้ไปแล้วก็เห็นอะไรฟังอะไร
น่ะดีๆอ้ะก็คือหมายถึงได้เจอน้าได้เจอแปล
ว่าเราได้เดินไปแล้วเราไปเห็นเดินๆไปแล้ว
เราก็ฟังได้ฟังอะไรดีๆ
เจอคือบอกว่าเจอแต่สิ่งดีๆ
เจอแต่สิ่งดีๆนะคะ
สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะขอให้ร่างกายแข็งแรงอาอ้า
ขอให้อาจใจแข็งแรง
ขอให้เจอสิ่งดีๆนะคะๆเจอคนดีเจอคนพูดดีๆ
เห็นอะไรดีๆๆ
นะใช่ช่องพูดแล้วคำอวยพร
ของวันที่ 1 มกราคมที่เป็นปีใหม่ทั่วโลก
กับคำอวยพรวันที่ 1
กุมภาพันธ์ที่เป็นปีใหม่จีนเหมือนกันไหม
คะ
อาจจะไม่เหมือนกันนิดหน่อยเนาะหน่อยเออคน
ไทยจีนชอบทำงานอ่ะชอบทำงานแล้วก็อาจจะคิด
เรื่องอ่ะอะธุรกิจและเงิน
ใช้เยอะๆ
และก็จะพูดอ้ะมั่งมีศรีสุขก็คืออะไรมั่ง
มีก็เกี่ยวกับเงินเฮงๆรวยๆก็เกี่ยวกับ
เรื่องเงินเงินนะคะแล้วก็ร่างกายแข็งแรง
นะว่าถ้าเป็นทางคนไทยคนไทยก็อยากจะอาจจะ
พูดถึงร่างกายแข็งแรงเฉพาะมีมีตำแหน่ง
มีชื่อเสียงเมื่อกี้คุยพูดชื่อเสียงใช่
ไหมชื่อเสียงคือมีคนคนคนอ่ะรู้จักรู้จัก
เยอะๆ
เราก็จะพูดถึงพูดถึงที่มันมองไม่เห็นจริง
ๆแต่ว่าเป็นเรื่องดีๆและภาษาไทยโอ๊ยพรปี
ใหม่ยากนะ
ใช่ค่ะคือครูเอ๋แล้วเอ๋ขอให้พรปีใหม่แบบ
คนไทยให้คนไทยพูดอะไรครูเรียม V ใช่ไหมคะ
เขียนอะไรอ่ะใช่ค่ะอ่ะพูดได้แต่ว่าอาจจะ
ยากนิดนึงใช่ค่ะคำอวยพรที่อยู่ในการ์ดยาว
มากยาวมากแล้วก็เป็นภาษาไทยที่เรียงคิด
ว่าอยู่ในขั้น
Advance
Advance  at  Advance  Advance  Advance
ใช่ประมาณ 3 แอบหวานขึ้น
บางบางคำอวยพรอ่ะในการ์ดอ่ะค่ะบางทีกู
อ่านแล้วเนี่ยให้คนไทยบางคนอ่านอะไร
ใช่ยากมา
8แปลว่าเข้าใจได้ง่ายๆก็ได้คู่เรียนน้อง
อ่านได้แล้วกูเองจะบอกนักเรียนใช่นัก
เรียนลองฟังดูนะคะอ่ะ
อยู่ในวาระดิถีขึ้นปีใหม่ขอ
วันปีใหม่
ขอมอบความปรารถนาดีขอให้คิดดีๆอันเนี้ย
ให้คุณ
และขอพรให้ท่านและครอบครัว
ขอ
พรอวยพรเนี่ยก็คือเป็นการคำพูดดีๆเหมือน
กับเราขอพรถ้าขอพรเนี่ยก็คือไม่ใช่รอให้
เท่านั้นแต่ว่าขอจากข้างบนใช่ไหมมีเรา
เรียกว่านักเรียนเราเรียกว่าสิ่ง
ศักดิ์สิทธิ์อ่ะสิ่งศักดิ์สิทธิ์เนี่ยคาด
คุณเป็นศาสนาคริสต์ใช่ไหมคะก็จากพระเจ้า
ถ้าคุณศาสนา
อิสลามก็จะทะเลาะเนาะใช่ไหมขาเลาะขอโทษนะ
คะถ้าพูดผิดถ้าเป็นพระมากินดูก็พระ
ศิวะศิวะพระนารายณ์พระพรหมนะคะคนไทยศาสนา
พุทธก็ไหว้พระ
มีใหม่เดี๋ยวคุยหาก่อน
คน a ไทยจีนอ่ะเจ้าแม่กวนอิม
มีพระแล้วก็อันนี้เจ้าแม่กวนอิมก็ก็พัก
เหมือนกันนะเนี่ยสิ่งศักดิ์สิทธิ์นะคะ
เรียงที่ 15 พี่เอมีเยอะมากๆอยู่ที่โต๊ะ
ชิงทรัพย์ศิษย์เยอะมากๆ
เอาไว้สอนพ่อ
ยังไม่
จบสักทีไอ้
อันนี้ผักพระนะคะฟ้า
พระอ่ะพระพุทธเจ้านะคะอันนี้เป็นพระสงฆ์
ราคะแบบพระรูปที่ 1 ก็คือพระพุทธเจ้า
ราคาก็พระพุทธเจ้าแล้วคุกนักเรียนรู้จัก
ให้พระพุทธเจ้าอ่ะนิดในถ้านักเรียนนัก
เรียนไป
ไปวัดนะคะ I วัดอนิด
วัด
วัดเนี่ยข้างในวัดก็จะมีอันนี้
[เพลง]
อันนี้เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าพระพุทธรูป
คำพุทธรูปเปิดซิง bongo แม่ก่อนคือพระ
พุทธเจ้า
แต่พระพุทธเจ้าเนี่ย
นิดทานไปแล้ว
ไปแล้วคือไม่พูดตายนะคะ
พูดว่าตายพูดว่า
ปรินิพพานแล้วนะปรินิพพานไปแล้วคนก็ปั้น
พระพุทธรูปงั้นพระพุทธรูปเนี่ยคนไทยบอก
ว่าสัตว์สิทธิ์นะคะ
เป็นสิ่งศักดิ์สิทธิ์เราไหว้นะคะไหว้
ไหว้พระพุทธรูป
งั้นเนี่ยที่
โคเรียมพูดถึงเนี่ยใช่ไหมคะว่าขอพรขอพร
น่ะเราก็จะขอจากพระพุทธรูป
ขอจ๊ะโอ้
พระเจ้ามาอ่านขอจากเทพนักที่เรารู้สึก
ไหว้แล้วเราก็ขอได้ขอแล้วก็ให้ใช่ขอให้มา
ให้ไปนะคะให้อันนี้ก็บอกว่าขอพรใช่มั้ย
ใช่ขอพรให้ประสบแต่ความสุข
ให้
มีความสุข
นะถ้าเกิดเรายิ้มเราก็มีความสุขไหมคะถ้า
ได้สะเออะมากๆใช่
ให้เสียใจก็ยิ้มไว้ก่อน
ยิ้มไว้ก่อน
ที่นี่ร้องไห้แต่น่ายินมัน
เอาว่าถ้ายิ้มแล้วเราดูเราเรายิ้มเสียใจ
ก็ไปบ่ายๆก็ยิ้ม
เช่น
และก็ไปนี้เป็นคำอวยพรสำหรับปีไหนราคาแปล
ว่า
เวลาเวลาปีใหม่
ปีไหนทาย MSX ปีใหม่วันที่ 1 มกราคมปี
ใหม่จีนน่ะ
คู๋พรครูเรียมโอเคคู่เรียมพรครูเอ๋
โอเคใช่ค่ะอา
วัน
สงกรานต์วันสงกรานต์เนี่ยเราจะมีน้ำเนาะ
น้ำน้ำน้ำสวยๆหอมๆแล้วเราก็จะไป
รดที่มือคุณพ่อคุณแม่
เออเราไม่ต้องคุณพ่อคุณแม่ขอให้แข็งแรง
อันนี้แอดนะ
แล้วจะเป็นคุณพ่อคุณแม่อวยพรให้เรามี
เนื้อนะครับวันสงกรานต์เนี่ยอาจไม่ใช่
เด็กพรผู้ใหญ่แบบผู้ใหญ่พรเด็กให้
เราไม่เหมือนกันแล้วนะ
ใช่ค่ะเตรียมก็
ไปอุ๊ยพรให้พี่เอ๋ไม่ได้ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะอ่า
ครูเรียมกับผัวทำงานด้วยกันพูดสวัสดีวัน
สงกรานต์โอเค
ผู้เรียนเป็นเด็กใช่ไหมคะอ่าให้เป็นๆเด็ก
ก็สวัสดีวันสงกรานต์โอเคเพื่อนกันด้วยทำ
งานอวยพรโอเคได้แต่ว่าถ้าเป็นครูเรียงมี
น้ำแล้วไปรดน้ำที่คุณพ่อคุณแม่อ่ะอวยพร
ให้คุณพ่อคุณแม่อ่ะบางคนทำนะคะ 8 จริงๆ
ต้องให้ผู้ใหญ่
ผู้ใหญ่พรให้เด็กเนื้ออันนี้คือ
สงกรานต์ผู้ใหญ่อวยพรเด็ก
แต่จะไหว้แล้วก็มีดอกไม้ก็ไปไหว้ผู้ใหญ่
ที่
a-one ที่เราไม่เข้าใจใช่ไหมเรามีน้ำ
อุ่นสวัสดีวันสงกรานต์ค่ะขอให้คุณแม่แข็ง
แรงคุณแม่ของพี่ไม่เป็นดีๆขอบคุณลูกให้
ลูกโชคดี
ใช่
ลูกอวยพรคุณแม่คุณแม่อวยพรลูกแต่ถ้าเป็น
เมื่อก่อนก็คือผู้ใหญ่พรเด็กอ๋อ
ผู้ใหญ่ต้องอวยพรให้นะคะปัจจุบันเด็กมวย
พรผู้ใหญ่ผู้ใหญ่อวยพรเด็กโอเคมั้ยใช่
พรผู้ใหญ่
พรเดียวตอนนี้ถ้าเป็นที่ทำงานได้เหมือน
กับวันวันปีใหม่วันเกิดวันตรุษจีนเนี้ย
คูเรียร์มีของขวัญแล้วก็ไปอ่ะให้อานายอด
สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะ
ได้มาสวัสดีวันสงกรานต์ค่ะอันเนี้ยได้
ก็อวยพรไปอวยพรมาเนาะใช่ค่ะเรื่องคิดว่า
วันนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว
กฎหมายเราพูดกันตอนไหนนะ 18:00 น 06:44
ใช่ไหมครับ 44 ตอนนี้อ่า
07:08 ยังไม่เวลานิดหน่อยเลยมีเวลานิด
หน่อยอ่าก็จะ 40  15 มีแต่ว่านักเรียน
วีดีโอพรปีใหม่อาจจะมีมวยพรแต่งงานด้วยนะ
อันนี้จะเป็นบอกให้รวยๆไม่ได้หรอคะเวลา
แต่งงานอ้อครูเตรียมส่งคุณครูเตรียมแต่ง
งานคูณแนะนำคู่เลี่ยมแต่งงานขอให้เฮงๆรวย
ๆได้ไหมคะ
ก็โอเคนะแต่แปลกๆ
ไม่รักแล้วแต่งงานต้องอวยพรว่ายังไงคะพี่
อวยพรว่าขอให้สองคนรักกันนานๆ
จนแก่ๆ
แล้วก็ขอให้สองคนแข็งแรง
ขอให้สองคนมีความสุขใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็มีลูก
ของใช่มั้ยท้องแล้วก็มีลูกคลอดลูก
มากๆ
โอเคไหมลูกมากๆก็คือไม่ใช่ 1 คน 1 คน 2
คน 3 คน 4 คนหน้าคน 6 มี 7 คนแต่ตอนนี้
2,000  22 คนไม่อยากมีลูกมากๆอยากจะมี
ลูก 1 คนทอก็จะอวยพรว่าออกสองให้สองคนรัก
กันนานๆร่างกายแข็งแรงอ่ะมีลูกเร็วๆก็
อ๊อดใช่แต่งงาน
2,000  22
2023 มีรูป
แล้วก็
รวยรวยๆนะ
คะใช่ค่ะก็จะพูดว่าขอให้โชคดีอย่างเงี้ย
ใช่เพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนเตรียมได้ยินคนอวยพร
วันแต่งงานว่าขอให้มีลูกเต็มบ้านใช่ถ้า
บ้านเล็กก็มี 4 คนบ้านใหญ่บักใหญ่
ขอ
ให้มีลูกมากๆมีลูกเต็มบ้านเลยบ้านเรามี
ลูก
โลกเยอะๆนะตอนนี้มีลูก 1 คนแพงก็โอเคมี
ลูกเร็วๆจะหนึ่งคนสองคนโอเคไม่พูดมีลูก
เต็มบ้าน
ให้ใช่อ่ะลูกเต็มบ้านไม่เอามาคือจ่ายจ่าย
เยอะมากๆมีลูกเต็มบ้าน
ถ้าวันนี้นักเรียนก็
ฟังเกี่ยวกับคำอวยพรถ้าเป็นปีใหม่ก็ก็
พรเกี่ยวกับให้โชคดีร่างกายแข็งแรงนะคะปี
ใหม่จีนก็เฮงเฮงๆรวยๆนะคะมั่งมีศรีสุขมาย
เราก็ถ้าแต่งงานก็ขอให้รักกันนานๆร่างกาย
แข็งแรงนะก็มีความสุขมีลูกมากๆมีลูกเร็วๆ
มีรูปโดเรม่อนน่ารักๆแล้วทักเป็นสงกรานต์
ก็สวัสดีวันสงกรานต์ค่ะสวัสดีวันสงกรานต์
ค่ะสวัสดีวันสงกรานต์นะคะ
[เพลง]
ผู้ใหญ่อวยพรให้ถ้าผู้ใหญ่อวยพรให้เราก็
จะขอให้ทำงานดีๆขอให้ร่างกายแข็งแรงนะลูก
เป็นคนดีนะแบบเนี้ยอ้ะใช่ดูคล้ายๆกันแต่
ไม่เหมือนกันนะคะไม่เหมือนคำไม่เหมือน
จริงๆภาษามียากกว่านี้แต่ตอนนี้มีกินาครู
เรียมกับครูเอกก็เลยพูดง่ายๆก่อนนะคะใช่
ค่ะนักเรียนก็พูดได้ชายอันนี้หมดเวลาจริง
ๆแล้วครูเรียมได้ให้นักเรียนขาโคเรียมกับ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยต้องแต่จริงๆแล้วนะคะไปแล้วนา
ๆค่ะไว้เจอครูเอ๋กับโคเรียมในคลิปหน้านะ
คะช่องพร้อมเพย์สิเบิ้ลไทยค่ะงั้นคืนนี้
คุณเอกกับครูเรียมไปก่อนนะคะบ๊ายบายค่ะ
บ๊ายบายนักเรียนทุกคนฟังภาษาไทยเก่งๆถ้า
เย้ขอบคุณค่ะ
นักเรียนเรียนนักเรียนบอกว่าขอบคุณค่ะมาก
ๆขอบคุณค่ะนะคะเฮงนะคะพี่อะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ
[เพลง]